[Music]
the recent debate over copyright laws
like SOPA in the United States and the
Act agreement in Europe has been very
emotional and I think some dispassionate
quantitative reasoning could really
bring a great deal to the debate I
therefore like to propose that we employ
we enlist the cutting-edge field of
copyright math whenever we approach this
subject for instance just recently the
Motion Picture Association revealed that
our economy loses fifty eight billion
dollars a year to copyright theft now
rather than just argue about this number
a copyright mathematician will analyze
it and he'll soon discover that this
money could stretch from this auditorium
all the way across Ocean Boulevard to
the West End and then to Mars if we use
pennies now this is obviously a powerful
some might say dangerously powerful
insight and it's also a morally
important one because this isn't just
the hypothetical retail value of some
pirated movies that we're talking about
but this is actual economic losses this
is the equivalent to the entire American
corn crop failing along with all of our
fruit crops as well as wheat tobacco
rice sorghum whatever sorghum is losing
sorghum but identifying the actual
losses to the economy is almost
impossible to do unless we use copyright
math now music revenues are down by
about eight billion dollars a year since
Napster first came on the scene so
that's a chunk of what we're looking for
but total movie revenues across theaters
home video and pay-per-view are up and
TV satellite and cable revenues are way
off
other Content markets like book
publishing and radio are also up so this
small missing chunk here is puzzling
since the big content markets have grown
in line with historic norms it's not
additional growth that piracy has
prevented but copyright math tells us it
must therefore be foregone growth in a
market that has no historic norms one
that didn't exist in the 90s what we're
looking at here is the insidious cost of
ringtone piracy fifty billion dollars of
it a year which is enough at 30 seconds
a ringtone that could stretch from here
to Neanderthal times true
I have Excel the movie folks also tell
us that our economy loses over three
hundred and seventy thousand jobs to
content theft which is quite a lot when
you consider that back in 98 the Bureau
of Labor Statistics indicated that the
motion picture in DiDio industries were
employing two hundred and seventy
thousand people other data has the music
industry at about forty five thousand
people and so that job losses that came
with the internet and all that content
theft had therefore left us with
negative employment in our content
industries this is just one of the many
mind-blowing statistics that copyright
mathematicians have to deal with every
day and some people think that string
theory is tough
now this is a key number from the
copyright mathematicians toolkit it's
the precise amount of harm that comes to
media companies whenever a single
copyrighted song or movie gets pirated
Hollywood in Congress derive this number
mathematically back when they last sat
down to improve copyright damages and
made this law some people think this
number is a little bit large but
copyright mathematicians who are media
lobby experts are merely surprised that
it doesn't get compounded for inflation
every year now when this law first
passed the world's hottest mp3 player
could hold just 10 songs and it was a
big Christmas hit because what little
hoodlum wouldn't want a million and a
half bucks worth of stolen goods in his
pocket
these days an iPod Classic and hold
40,000 songs which is to say 8 billion
dollars with a stolen media for about 75
thousand jobs
now you might find copyright mouths
range but that's because it's a field
that's best left to experts so that's it
for now I hope you'll join me next time
when I will be making an equally
scientific and fact-based inquiry into
the cost of alien music piracy to the
American economy thank you very much
[Applause]